so let's get some reaction from labor
now Peter Carl is the shadow Northern
Ireland secretary and is here with me a
very good morning to you it's your brief
let's start with Northern Ireland what's
your reaction to the fact that the
politicians at Stormont failed to come
together to restore power sharing by the
midnight deadline what next how do we
break the Sam pass well we've had six
wasted months that's the problem uh
we're all focusing on this moment this
24 hours where the legislation says we
need to have another election but in the
last six months we've had three prime
ministers three secretaries of State for
Northern Ireland just last week we're
Seton Harris the secretary of state was
campaigning for Boris Johnson he wasn't
out there trying to bring parties
together there has been no multi-party
talks in the last six months now what
works in Northern Ireland is when the
Irish government and the British
government work together to provide a
stable framework for peace and
prosperity and progress in Northern
Ireland and what works when you have a
prime minister and a secretary of state
and a foreign secretary who really focus
on the needs of Northern Ireland and
commit the space which is soon has never
visited Northern Ireland as since he's
been in government unless he's been
campaigning for the leadership when he
goes to meet Tory party members so these
are the sorts of things that have really
created this period of instability and
the challenges in Westminster have
reinforced the negatives in Northern
Ireland not the positives so this next
six month period after this election has
got to be different than the one that
went before okay so you're putting this
all at the door of the Westminster
government but there are so many
different factors here aren't there and
one of the main problems is that the dep
said they won't return to power sharing
until the Northern Ireland protocol goes
they say that essentially treats
Northern Ireland differently to other
parts of the UK and that's a fundamental
problem there isn't it so what would
labor do about it well we've said from
the outset that we would fix the
problems with the protocol yeah it's
been almost 15 months since the British
government put forward its proposals for
a fast track across the uh the Irish sea
the EU it's been a year this week since
the EU before its proposals for a Green
Lane we are arguing about the same thing
it is inconceivable to me that we've not
made the progress that we need now a
year ago the dup were not saying they
were in a Stormont they were raising
concerns because of power sharing they
had the right to be taken on their own
terms and they were ignored it's only
when they actually acted if you forgive
the phrase for them in a dysfunctional
Way by pulling down the assembly and the
executive that suddenly government
started taking notice of them and in the
period since then their expectations
have grown because of the the sheer
disruption that's happened in Northern
Ireland we have allowed through Tory
neglect a dysfunction to embed itself in
Northern Ireland the divisions between
different communities to become
entrenched to become more divided than
they were before and the process that we
need to move people back together again
and heal some of these challenges and
move forward again seems just simply not
to be in place at the moment would you
say that and yet from you it feels like
there's more of the brexit blame game
going on by blaming the government now I
mean isn't it for everybody to coming
together including labor to be
absolutely right but I'm going to call
it out the way I see it I was over there
on Monday I was over there on Monday in
Stormont I met all political leaders of
all parties represented in Stormont
where was the Secretary of State he was
campaigning for Boris Johnson here in
Westminster you know we need to have
Focus now I would love to be able to get
involved in some of these things but I'm
doing everything I can do to make sure
that we we sow the seeds of
reconciliation and progress in Northern
Ireland but we need that position of
power to be able to do it we did it in
1998 from a position of Power with the
Good Friday agreement the government at
the moment are sowing divisions even
further I was over in the island of
Ireland for three days with Kia starma
we met the Irish president the Irish
president the Irish Prime Minister the
tea shop we went to the Northern Ireland
and met all the political leaders there
in Stormont we have a prime minister in
Waiting in kirstama a secretary of state
in uh waiting in me who wants to commit
the time and are already doing so from a
position of opposition we just need to
get into government so we can put it
into action okay and as far as the
elections are concerned they're now
going to be called again before
Christmas will that move things forward
do you think I think it's unlikely to
move forward but it will present another
six six months of opportunity let's make
this a six months where we don't waste
that opportunity I mean parties in
Northern Ireland I wish all parties were
there serving in storm on but it means
we also need here in Westminster to up
our game we need a Tory government that
will pay attention and create and
rebuild relationships with the Irish
government provide the framework for
peace and Reconciliation and progress in
Northern Ireland okay I want to move on
to other issues because there's so much
news around and not least the
announcement that Rishi sunak is not
going to cop27 what's your response to
that I think this is a huge shame we we
know from yesterday that the world is
not likely to meet the uh the The Net
Zero targets that we need and the the
global warming targets we need this this
would be a wake-up call for all of us we
need to be shocked into action but this
government seems to be shocked into
withdrawal you know this government has
a policy of global Britain so it's not
just about climate change even though
that is of Paramount importance it's
about Britain participating in the way
that the globe comes together the world
comes together to solve problems if
we're not there around the table on
climate change then why would the rest
of the world look to Britain to
leadership in other areas as well well
Terry's Coffee spoke to me earlier
environment Secretary of course and she
says it's not normal for all the leaders
to go every year it's normally the big
focus is on every five years and last
year cop26 was that big focus and it's
true isn't it that Richie sunac has a
huge amount on his plate he's got this
very important awesome budget which
falls in the dates of of cop27 and and
isn't it right that that should be his
focus at a time like that Teresa coffee
is wrong for many reasons let me give
you two firstly we are president of cop
right now and we're handing that over to
Eastern cop 27 we are president for a
half of the uh half of the conference
and we will hand over but we have that
moment where we're still president we're
the people that should be providing
energy commitment in into cop27 so that
we hand over a presidency that is in
good shape and we're not even turning up
as prime minister we're Banning the king
from going we're not going to have the
representation there that shows Britain
is fully committed and for the second
reason we now know that we are in a
worse State when it comes to climate
change than we were a year ago this is
more important we can't wait for five
years five yearly intervals before the
Tory prime minister gives a damn about
climate change well we now need to make
sure that we are there when those
crucial moments are being decisions are
being taken and right now we need to
make sure our presidency ends with a
bang it ends with energy going into the
next presidency because the world is
failing in its climate change emissions
and Britain's okay leading not
withdrawing he says he is committed to
to Net Zero commitments and he also is
saying that he's got lots of other
pressing concerns and not least this
Autumn statement and it is an issue the
economy isn't it I mean let me just show
you a poll that's our you may well have
seen it I think it's on the front of the
eye newspaper they've used bgm to do a
survey and they're now saying that the
new prime minister Rishi sunak is more
trusted with the economy also more
trusted with tax as and also with
business as well
compared to to case Pharma should labor
be worried about that well she said
that's only been in the job a couple of
days well he's in the in job a couple of
days which means you're usually get a
bit of a honeymoon period but the key
thing is that when kirst armor took over
as leader of the labor party he was
minus 32 percent when it came to economy
and tax and the issues you're raising
here right now he's been ahead for quite
a while considerable amount of time on
the economy and trustworth and being
trustworthy he's still seen as more
Prime ministerial than Rishi sunak but
on those key issues the thing that's
given Wishy sunak a bit of a bump and
the Tory is a bit of a bump on the
economy is because they keep adopting
labor policies on the windfall tax for
example a labor policy right now you're
going to see a whole bunch of other
areas
the fact that he was Chancellor and
oversaw the furlough and people people
seem to think that he makes sense and
the economy according to these polls at
least and they're asked the questions
over what labor would do but you see
like says he's going to miss cop he's
going to focus on on the Autumn
statement but there are questions about
how labor would fill that the Autumn
statement is intensified there's no
question about that now because we've
been talking about this since the summer
we wouldn't have had the mini budget
which crashed the economy a crisis made
in Downing Street being paid for by
every worker up and down our country so
they got us into this mess the the
Autumn statement is about how they get
us out of the mess that they got us into
so yes I think the country is relieved
that we have a new prime minister and
it's not Liz trust anymore but don't
forget that this is a government which
is made up of people through grubby
deals it's not up there it's not made up
of a government of Talon which is there
to face the challenges that the
government that the country faces right
now this is a government full of fixes
that can fix the challenges of the Tory
back benches is not a government that's
there to fix the challenges our country
cases in kirstama they they know that
they have somebody who is focused on the
priorities of the country country first
party second he said at our labor party
conference and got Innovation for it
with this lot it is party first and
Country second okay well we'll put you
down on details of the government of
Labor's tax and spending plans next time
Peter Carlo we're out of time now thanks
very much indeed